[Music]
i will reiterate for people who didn't
hear the first episode you look like
you're 60. it is remarkable uh certainly
something to aspire to and removes any
excuses i might have
and
i have notes in front of me with a
number of things that i would love to
discuss the
the first
is
developing awareness and i
i have a note here about recording or
recording your weight
what is your suggestion for people and
is this something that you have done
yourself
yes
first of all i had a relative who was
significantly overweight
and he
he wished to lose weight
and so i said the first thing you do
i'm not going to tell you what to eat or
how to eat or anything else the first
thing you do is you get on the scale
every morning
and you write down the date
and how much you wait
and just observe that number and do that
day after day
well turned out he didn't really want to
lose weight and so after a while he
stopped doing this
and so
i got after him and him through it again
for a while and then he quit again and
his weight would go down and bounce back
up and go down and bounce back up but
when he was writing it down it seemed to
alter his behavior and
he would his weight would slowly drift
downward
so
i've made a habit myself of getting on
the scale maybe not every morning
because i don't need to anymore but for
a long time i'd get on
every morning and just observe what i
weighed and
i've been pretty well bracketed between
151 and about 158 for as long as i can
remember
and if i get near 158 i uh
i say well you know i don't need that
dessert tonight or that beer we'll have
it some other time
or hop out a great big healthy salad
today instead of a burger
and uh that's enough to shift me down
and then i have another little thing
that i checked you know there
there's a simplistic notion of
apples and pears in people
i don't know have you heard about this
one
i have
an apple is somebody that tends toward
getting a big pot belly when they gain
weight
and i come from a family of apples
and this is not healthy because you get
all this fat around your internal organs
so one of the things i put on my list
early was never get that potbelly
so all i have to do is i can look down
if i see anything that isn't flat down
there i know i way too much
that's another awareness needs to change
things those two feedbacks are more than
enough to control my weight for a
lifetime and i really have to use them
but anyhow i would say that a person can
develop their own feedbacks whatever
those are
and use them and measurement is
important because
you want facts
on which to base what you do instead of
hopes beliefs wishes so on
i remember a t-shirt that i was given a
long time ago by the
director james cameron it was actually
an original staff shirt
for the film avatar and the very top of
it said hope is not a strategy which i
liked
which i liked quite a lot
and your weighing
just to get specific is before breakfast
and without clothes or what you would
recommend is that is that accurate i do
two things
when that's convenient i do that
when it's not convenient
i just happen to go to the scale maybe
before a shower in the middle of the day
and i weigh myself and put that down as
a little side fact and of course i'm
gonna weigh more in the middle of the
day than i did first thing in the
morning so i know that
so maybe i weigh 1 52 in the morning
but when i put my little side thing down
i might say at 3 pm i say 154 and a half
so i know that roughly speaking about
each third of the day correspond to each
possible meal i gain about one pound
so
i can mentally correct back to the
beginning of the day
i don't have to weigh myself every
morning if it's not convenient
but i get other feedback
right absolutely
the whole thing about health and fitness
as i see it is
you want to do things that are
preventative
and
you want to make sure you're not missing
something important
because it's the things you miss
that are going to do more damage than
the
positive things
are to save you i mean you can work out
and be fit and have high aerobics and so
on but if you're not going in for a
routine colonoscopies and skin cancer
checks and so on you're leaving up a big
risk factor open for yourself
so you've got to try to get rid of the
risks
that uh you can cover
do you have a checklist for yourself or
how do you ensure that you are not
missing
gaps or blind spots
i think about it and i talk to people
and i i pick up information all over my
my list expands you know there's a lot
of a lot of topics on the list there's a
physical fitness of various kinds
there is mental health
there's
supplements which
i
don't take much of because the evidence
isn't strong enough in my mind for them
other people will disagree but i'm not
heavy on supplements
only if i think they've really been
proven one thing that i i found that
really worked well was
bone supplements
and
i was able to reverse
osteopenia and turned into
excess bone after uh several years
bone supplements meaning say calcium
magnesium k2 blends things of that type
yeah
i have a few bullet points that i would
love to hear you expand on and actually
before i get to that i should say that
it is incredible how much behavioral
change can subconsciously seep into
someone's life also consciously but
i i find the subconscious side
especially interesting if they simply
begin to measure
whether it's body weight or body
composition
which is partially why
self-directed observational studies or
at-home
clinical trials or experiments are so
difficult
to design well because you can you can
say to someone all right you're going to
follow the mediterranean diet keep all
of your other variables the same don't
change anything else but rarely is that
going to be the case
so that's just a side note
you